foreign
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
hello
[Music]
I have to have to have to skip it what
is it I have two had two scoop up Scoot
About putt two hot two hot two hot Skips
a quarterback a quarterback yeah that is
it I think it's too hot too Scooby-Doo
hot two hot two hot two skip it up two
yeah yeah that's from life stinks with
Mel Brooks and I laughed so hard at that
part when I was a kid when he's trying
to pedal for change uh because he saw
the kid doing it and he needs money
right
he needs he's like a formerly Super Rich
Beverly Hills yup producer maybe even
okay and he's like a shitty guy yeah I
know that right yeah well I'm telling
the audience because we're recording I
know I already know that so skip the
part so
that's the kid doing it that's the kid
doing it and he sees the kid do it
again boom hop too
but then Mel does it yes and it sucks
ass and no one gives me we can't see it
on screen but we can hear it yeah it's
not up
fix that
fix it there it is oh it wasn't even on
no fix it again you did it wrong now
it's just black now it's black there we
go there we go there it is
there we go yeah here we go here we go
there it is
this is great so he needs money he sees
this kid being good at it and making
money off of it
this made me laugh hard dude
everybody likes it thinks he's cute and
good how much did that kid grow up in
that cancer
oh yeah he made the money right all in
the days work baby
I mean so taking the time with the scene
I love it that's good yeah it is good no
I knew what that before you
dude
hot too hot too they're gonna be bomb
boom never mind hot two hot twos they're
gonna be
the guy's shaking his head
there's some punch lines thing at the
end
hot too
dude the the if that were made oh wow
remember that we gotta watch that again
it's a good movie remember that dude
that movie there was uh
what do you call it
what was it gonna say nobody knows but
you God damn it that movie oh if that
movie was made wow that was really loud
if that movie was made today it would be
that scene would be so different huh
you think so yeah it will be cut close
to his face Oh you mean as a filmmaker
yeah yeah I mean like if it was a Judd
appetite thing it would have been like
70 Cuts yeah and music during it yeah no
Brooks is the genius dude yeah I don't
know why they don't let [ __ ] play a lot
like that I watched The Internship the
other day remember oh with Vince Vaughn
and Owen Wilson I sent you the clip yeah
I never saw that Vince Vaughn's so funny
I agree uh and Owen wasn't funny too but
Vince Vaughn man uh and it was it was uh
and that director went on to do some big
[ __ ] who directed The Sean Levy you know
who he is oh yeah yeah yeah and that
movie is it has its moments but I feel
like it was like trying to be something
that was like okay we did Reddit
Crashers now let's do this definitely
and they were both like we're both
salesmen you guys will Thrive off this
as actors and improv artists you know
and it just smelled like that it was too
much of that it was like produced piece
by piece being like well that made money
and that yeah yeah and that's a good
idea and that's happening right now but
um anyway happy New Year it is uh
the second epic right because New Year's
was the first episode Sunday or well I
don't know yeah and uh it's the new year
uh but this is the uh the popping New
Year the the year as Matt said you're
the bing bong and it's [ __ ] cold in
here huh I'm hot I'm not cold at all I
feel like [ __ ] though shut me down the
thing about 2023 so far is it's not only
the year of the Bing Bong it's the year
of film like [ __ ] so far for me and is
it because of the of the rate no I mean
almost died
is it because of the rain uh no it's not
because the rains because it's because
I've had a [ __ ] cold oh really for
too long and it's not going away and
every day I wake up and I do the a gross
thing I'm not gonna do it right now with
my throat and my nose okay you know yeah
it has the it's like it's
kind of like that yeah uh and it pisses
me off yeah so what's going on I'm sure
it pisses you off dude uh and it's too
cold and it's too raining and I hate the
rain and it's and and it's sadness so
that's great
I can't stand a rain
uh it's sadness you know yeah poetry so
um anyway dude it's good to be in the
year 2023 who knew we would we would
[ __ ] make it to 2023. it's tough to
make it to 2023 if you made it to 2023
congratulations dude
um we got the uh the channel here that
you can like And subscribe to
um it is uh Shadow band 100 we're
probably gonna have to change the name
to make it not Shadow band 100 yeah
because it's [ __ ] awful we can't we
can't break subscribers uh so subscribe
but we got uh I got Brea
um coming up here in California I got
Portland Seattle these are dates
um oh wait when does this come out
Sunday so you know what tonight I'll be
in San Diego you can get your tickets
chrisley.com uh Jacksonville San Antonio
uh Minneapolis we just added a show and
uh Sugarland we're gonna be there Austin
we just added a show Boise Columbus
Cincinnati we got dates all over and uh
be on the lookout for Salt Lake City is
coming up and I believe uh somewhere
else I can't remember what it is but
that's coming up so anyway I keep adding
dates chrisley.com uh go to get them
tickets it's a dick but all good dude we
don't need it oh you're done yeah yeah
if you have a question click the link in
the description below or go to watch
lifeline.com and uh we've got that great
new Lifeline merch at lifelinemirch.com
and if you want one-on-one advice
sessions with me your boy your Bing Bong
boy Matt Delia uh go to matalia.com I've
been giving good advice to all you
people who've been making sessions with
me uh I would say 95 of the time I feel
like they're very very productive and
there's always that five percent where
I'm like there was one session where I
literally
literally had no idea what the guy was
saying the entire time whoa he was he
was speaking English oh yeah he was he
was just the words didn't go together
like I'm assuming he thought they were
but he was just like a fully
unwell guy you know what I'm saying yeah
uh and besides him it was all good Okay
cool so all right yeah I can't I don't
want to air it out too much because he
was he was like sweet but something was
just about it I hope he's okay and I'm
I'm unqualified to help with that right
right you know what I mean not me I'm
qualified no you're not dude you know
what you should do call me in those
situations what situations where you
don't understand somebody dude I can get
to the [ __ ] bottom of it I'm chilled
no I'm chilled right now chilled yeah
I'm just chilled dude that's not the
right way to say that and I'm not gonna
lie I didn't get good sleep
okay did you no actually I didn't get
really bad sleep I normally get good
sleep didn't get good sleep and upset
and I'm upset about it so uh we really
hope that you guys are getting good
sleep keep taking take care of your
mental health you know what I mean take
care of your sleep schedule that's the
most important thing and uh and that's
that man take naps bring back naps in
2023. yeah I used to take naps and then
I moved and in the house I live now I do
not take naps and it's The house's fault
yes dude there's nowhere to nap in that
house
except in the bed I guess but I nap on
couches but where I'm saying and you're
in the house that you live in now on the
couch there's no good place to nap
you know why why because it's always 97
degrees in your house dude you are a
[ __ ] orchid
you live in a hot house
it's horrible
I live in a a well and it's not that
house it's any house or any room that
you have the control of the temperature
it's too cold always
but maybe I have a [ __ ] arm
deficiency or something but I don't eat
so much salmon dude you know I keep it
lean and like it's crazy dude okay well
anyway you like it
disgustingly warm Calvin loves pasta and
we ate pasta last night and it was so
[ __ ] cute dude he's like no I want
parmesan cheese and he kept on wanting
parmesan cheese and I kept having to put
parmesan cheese on the thing and that's
how you know he's a dahlia you know how
that and I do it let's be honest what
everyone's kid is only cute to them no
because saying I want parmesan cheese
alone isn't cute yes it is dude it is if
your kid is cute and some kids are
[ __ ] so cute and some kids are not
cute am I sure you're so cute if a kid
is cute then everything they do is cute
right but my kids only when they do it
like when somebody tells a story like uh
my kid was like I want parmesan cheese
it's like okay okay but you know Calvin
so just imagine him doing it you're
welcome that sounds very nice doesn't it
I've seen him do that yep so it's so
cute uh yeah he's I mean cow is super
cute and he has a [ __ ] cut here and
he keeps picking it we had to put a
Band-Aid on it he's had it for so long
it looks like it's like a birthmark I
know it she just won't stop picking it
dude and it'll wake up in them I'll go
in the morning get him in from his crib
and he'll be like I picked my boo-boo oh
really Kevin I tell you not to pick it
so anyway we make him sleep with the
Band-Aid on now whatever that's how it
goes and so it goes and so it goes
terrible rap
absolutely all right what is it round
and round no no one knows no one likes
it no one likes it no that song that
song is [ __ ] banging dude no one
likes what you're doing do you know who
it is
Joel and so yeah
why do you do every song like you're
Josh Groban because you because Josh
roping my ass dude because that's my
style dude and and that's a terrible
style it is especially because someone
else already has it and he's Josh grew
up in my ass that's so dumb dude all
right so Josh Groban is very good at
what he does I agree don't we don't need
two Josh Groban masses I'm not doing it
like Josh Groban I'm inspired like Josh
Groban and and I have Inspirations just
like I do with my comedy right Jim
Carrey Murphy that's my inspiration I'm
not like them but I grew up on them and
since I grew up on Josh Groban even
though we're the same age now when I
started doing my singing grow up on
Joshua I grew up on Eddie Murphy uh Jim
Carrey and Josh Groban okay and so it
goes and and one of the things that I
learned is when you really hit the
[ __ ] hard notes and so it goes and
you gotta [ __ ] pull back because it
gets loud in people's ears yeah if only
you put back so far you're on the other
side of the wall That's dick shall we
yeah let's do it all right let's do it
hi Chris haima I absolutely [ __ ] out of
the both of you but
my upstairs neighbor wakes me up at 7 on
the dot every single day Monday through
Sunday it doesn't matter
um and it's because their dog barks
Howl's cries and runs around in the
mornings and as I'm sure we all know by
now there's nothing more obnoxious than
being woken up against your own will
like it's one thing if you have to set
an alarm for a certain time to wake up
but it's another thing if you're woken
up by like a lawnmower outside or
somebody waking you up when you fall
asleep on the couch or in my case when a
dog is barking
um and I work from home I just feel like
it sets the tone for my day really wrong
because I wake up pissed off and I
already sent a message to my leasing
office not that I expect them to get
like evicted but I just wanted them to
send an anonymous tip and be like hey
you guys are being kind of loud clearly
it didn't [ __ ] work so I feel like I
have to take matters into my own hands
but I'm not a confrontational person
like it's not my nation to be like hey
you got you [ __ ] it you know so I was
thinking of maybe writing a letter I
don't know if there's a way to like spin
move out of this but it's to a point now
where it's ruining my piece because I
can also hear them doing like the
horizontal Mambo later and like walking
around like it's just very annoying
I mean okay so the dog barking I got an
I got a really good I dude I got a
really good idea do you want to go first
and it's just very simple okay get a
[ __ ] sound machine crank it up and
put it near your head on your head yep
put it tape it to the front of your head
turn it on and just hear waves dude a
sound machine is really great awesome I
know but I do use earplugs those don't
work at all for me okay well they work
for me it's probably because your ears
are [ __ ] up in some way my ears are
[ __ ] up but oh okay well there you go
hers are nothing probably and mine are
not so if you just ball them up ball
them up Bing Bong in the ear and they
just you make them small and then you
put them in there and then they expand
and you can't hear anything but really
on that if you want the neighbor at 7am
with the dog you can't be okay when you
live in any kind of apartment complex or
whatever like on on top of one another
you can't have something that is waking
other people up seen hours I agree seven
isn't obscene like to everyone but it is
to a lot of people especially on
weekends it's too early yeah and like
you gotta that person has to figure out
how to make their dog stop annoying
their neighbors or get a house
or be on the streets well you don't want
to have a dog live on the streets that's
not nice right or also you don't want to
live on the streets but uh but a person
can make that choice a dog
they should be out on the streets though
honestly
I mean that's let's face it they come
from wolves
nothing that means nothing they aren't
wolves anymore they're completely
defenseless and okay but they would all
die if they got let out on this I know
but dogs well there's probably enough
trash in La at least okay [ __ ] for
them to eat anyway I'm just saying that
I think the thing to do also besides
taking measures that you can do to your
for yourself I think you write them a
note tape it on their door you don't
need to knock and confront them right if
you're not confrontational it's not like
a scaredy cat move or something no
totally free to do that I've done I've
done both both work uh both piss people
off but who cares like yeah this is your
sleep like Chris was just talking about
like yeah your sleep matters be nice
about it though and the letter this way
this is what I like to do okay be nice
about it in the letter this way if
they're a dick back you go like this I
tried now the gloves come off you get a
stool and late at night you stand up and
you sh you
you know angle your and so it goes and
so it goes round and round no one knows
or whatever the lyrics are and she
probably doesn't want to do that and
nobody wants to do that and no Billy
Joel and I probably want to do it but
yeah I you know and I think that singing
Warfare those two things you know takes
things measures that you know will make
it easier for you to sleep on your own
with the earplugs or the sound machine
whatever
uh and also write a note write a note to
them so you have so you have ears that
work when you put the thing those orange
ones right mine are blue okay so you
painted them so you put them in your ear
and then they expand right yes and then
uh they're like foam yeah I understand
I've tried it and they don't fall out no
no don't I oh my [ __ ] is like it'll be
for 30 minutes but I have air pods and
they're in my ears and then all of a
sudden they're not in my ears no so your
your the holes in your ears especially
one of them I think it just slopes down
and it just falls out yeah yeah you have
faulty ears those those aren't she
doesn't have faulty ears I would imagine
and I certainly don't have faulty ears
do those orange thingies work for you
guys leave a comment because I don't
those those years yeah because they
don't work for me dude so I want to know
if they work for you because I want to
know if my ears are [ __ ] up or if it's
like a large pop part of the population
that just can't use those [ __ ] things
no they're cheap and they're effective
and they're great otherwise they
wouldn't sell nobody would buy them if
they always [ __ ] didn't work for
everybody but that's not true because it
is a bit of a sucker gift right like it
is a bit of a sucker thing you see and
like oh cool and then you get it and it
doesn't work but oh well they already
got your [ __ ] 690 a sucker gift who's
gifting people for yourself I'm saying
oh you're gifted you say oh I I deserve
a treat right because this is me I mean
not necessarily something I need but it
might be nice to have earplugs and then
you put it in and then it doesn't work
it falls out I'm wondering if it happens
to you so leave a comment no but what
sometimes will happen is that it'll
expand in the wrong way and it'll leave
room for unauthorized sounds to get
through yeah and when I want the uh the
unauthorized sounds that they sneak in
yeah so what you have to do what I have
to do sometimes is take it out
ball it up bing bong and put it right
back in there it it it it I the way I do
it always has unauthorized sound when it
comes in it always sneaks in and then
also it always falls out you know you
can get large ones
or like extra I didn't know that but I
feel like those will just really yeah
yeah there's like the normal sized and
then there's large ones for people that
have [ __ ] up heads like you okay
all right well then I guess we could do
that yep should I get a haircut
no I mean you think it looks nice
whatever I think I need to get a trim
I'm gonna get a trim whatever I'm gonna
get a trim and I'll have it next time
you see me and then also I'm bringing
Calvin to get his first [ __ ] haircut
professional haircut because I do it
make Kristen do it and you're saying
that's going to stop now and you're
going to take him to an actual Barber
this is the first time I'm gonna do it
okay and I want to see you know I want
to see him look like a real like
handsome like a cool cut yeah okay but I
feel like my hair is kind of good but
then when I cut my hair and then I look
back I'm like my hair was too long what
the [ __ ] was I doing oh I know what you
mean you know what I'm saying yeah
but I never um you know get my hair cut
so I don't know what to say okay well I
think I'm looking kind of good though
yeah whatever yeah I'm insecure
you know I want acceptance from
everybody okay
ever since I was a little kid okay so uh
relax
and I just want people to know I want
people to tell me I'm okay as I am okay
well good luck to you right very nice
woman that just called in and that sucks
but try the earplugs maybe the sound
machine if I don't know those might be
expensive uh and then write a note and
if the note response is either nothing
happens
or they're rude back to you you might
have to suck it up and bing bong
knock on the door and then when I'm in
my car and I do affirmations out loud
sometimes when I do the I'm worthy of
loved one I start crying so let's go to
the next one
what's up Chris and Matt what's up I
have what I think
is a hot button topic okay you know some
of those like really important issues
yeah
and um
I think those are worse I've had this
issue where I watched television and
film
I think they're dumb movies whatever and
I've seen it happen so much where
um nobody ever says goodbye when they
hang up on them oh dude
in movies film
um television I don't understand like it
seems so [ __ ] cool to do but also at
the same time it seems like such a
[ __ ] thing to do so deep and I was
thinking and also at the same time I
just don't understand why it's like so
broad spectrum across yeah that's true
like are people meeting together is
there like some sort of rule like you
can't have people say goodbye when they
hang up the phone on television or film
it's in every actor's contract please
help me understand this obviously I'm
probably not gonna hang up on people but
I don't know maybe I'll try it out
um anyway let me know your thoughts of
the world try it out maybe I'll change
the world I noticed this all the time I
love this dude what an observation I
always think of this it's so annoying
and and the other they never cut to the
other person on the other line like
oh
like dude all right I can't say I don't
think I've noticed it the way you guys
are talking oh really dude we first
noticed it but I've never been like what
in every first of all any badass movie
nobody says bye yeah okay here's what I
have worked on in my head why they do it
okay it's just unnecessary for the
filmmaking yeah yeah you just want it to
keep moving yeah we want real life go
look at somebody on their cell phone
right you want to see Denzel be the
[ __ ] [ __ ] you don't hear him say okay
great I got the instructions for the
assassination bye-bye you know what I
mean got instructions for the
assassination that sounds that's a
that's a good writing oh so let's put it
this way let's let's understand
something nobody ever actually really
says buy once even on the phone in real
life writing what I mean you say more
than once you go like this all right
okay cool all right well I'll see you
later yup okay uh-huh all right yeah
okay great uh-huh I'll see you all right
this sounds good yep ah bye imagine it
but again doing it but again that would
suck and it would be boring and we don't
want real life when we go to the movies
yeah the thing I hate that's kind of
similar but I have one too better
observation than that even is it's
exclusive to TV movies don't do this
okay the scene will
for all intents and purposes
end right but
the camera will Linger on one or maybe
even sometimes both of the of the actors
involved in the scene so it'll be like
the child is missing and the other
person's like oh my God is he really and
then the other person would be like but
maybe I know where the child is and then
it'll cut to the back the other person
and it'll be like three more seconds
just being like
it's like the scene's done dude dude why
are you doing that because in the script
it says off of Karen's reaction we smash
cut too but it could be way shorter I
know nobody does I mean if you want to
talk about nobody does that in real life
conversations keep going nobody at the
end of every big moment in the
conversation right people don't just go
yeah yeah yeah whatever you know what I
mean I mean I'm a good actor so what I
just did was probably really good but
yeah every scene that Scott Bakula has
ever been in definitely Scott back had
that happen especially NCIS dude I love
Scott back oh he's in one of those have
you seen it is it New Orleans I've never
seen it no oh dude
yo what's up with it it's
fantastic oh it's good dude
so first of all his name is
pull up his name dude he is a white
hammer or something it is Dwight it is
yep oh my God no no you know what it is
Dwayne oh wow what is the name of it
Dwayne
what you want to do is look up here
and then he's doing all that
NCIS
Dwight Dwayne
and so yeah uh why isn't it oh there it
is in the fifth one the fifth one right
there
the picture
the picture picture
now we go down say it he said
what we're doing is we're pissing me off
yeah okay
especially because you forgot his
microphone so now we can't even hear him
right right Scott bavacula you know
foreign
there we go
it was worth the wait it was worth the
wait wow Dwayne Pride dude here's the
thing wow they don't even call him that
they call him King
why why is it ever explained hey King
look it's his nickname that's his or
he's like a crown like off the side of
his head in the streets they say we
found the kid that cut to him like this
he's got the crown dude it is and then
they got that other guy in it the guy
who always acts like this the Lucas guy
who's in the fast furious
uh black yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what's
his name in it who's the comedian Lucas
Black Lucas no you're thinking of uh
someone else
this guy's NCIS what's his name Lucas
Black there he is who's the guy I'm
thinking of though uh the guy who talks
like this the comedian yeah uh why don't
we know imagine if he was in NCIS dude
Dwayne Pride call me king
um so his crown keeps falling off
because he's all jittery um so Lucas
Blackie oh every time he talks he talks
like this and he's like well King I'll
figure it out well who's Daryl
Mitchell's character's name Patton Plame
oh dude
okay right above Mark no that guy Daryl
Mitchell yeah isn't into what Peril hold
on a second though in the opening
credits of NCIS
New Orleans
Daryl Mitchell when his name when his
title card comes up in the beginning it
doesn't say
it doesn't say Daryl Mitchell even
though that's his name yeah it is what
it says is
Daryl chill Mitchell what the [ __ ] is
going on with this show dude that's so
dope he's so chill and here's the thing
he plays a guy in a wheelchair and I was
like wow that's [ __ ] probably they
would probably do that now they'd
probably get a real guy who did a real
one then I looked it up he is in a
wheelchair and and that is chill dude
yeah that is chill but he goes by chill
yeah dude watch watch that's sick
this guy that's Neil Brennan
oh yeah
unbelievable dude honestly I'm Matt
chill Delia yeah yeah oh yeah so and so
okay so so it's all good so here's the
deal that is about
uh NCIS wow dude uh which by the way
nobody knows what it is NCIS right like
it has to do with the Navy or some [ __ ]
and it's like okay right but it's always
NCIS is
that have to do with the Sea and the
Navy and [ __ ] what that's so narrow so
weird this should be three episodes it's
like whatever it's like there was these
these fish rob the bank I don't know
what the [ __ ] but so and so we gotta go
get a bunch of a bunch of [ __ ] uh
barracudas went to good they they're
they're in a crime ring and so um
so
this is everything that has to do with
the naval criminal investigative service
I can't believe how successful it is I
mean Mark Harmon who's in the first one
is obviously worth 85 billion dollars
yes
um he's 107. and so the the but CIS was
first right CIS was oh is that was it
CIS or CSI no CSI crime service
investigation okay CIS what the [ __ ]
okay so so there they they have a an
office or I don't know what you'd call
it the offices of the executive call it
in office but yeah but like it's not a
Precinct right like it's called
something isn't it I don't know and I've
never seen the show okay so dude it is
the most decked out chillest [ __ ] it's
in like an old abandoned [ __ ]
refurbished place that would be so dope
to live for a bachelor right and dude
there's a kitchen in it and Dwayne Pride
AKA King's thing is he's always cooking
for everyone everyone else because he's
like he's probably like a Cajun guy yeah
go and it's like that's what we do in
New Orleans yeah yeah wow what a
dumpster anybody want and Dooley that's
how everything starts he's like anybody
wanting Dewey sausage and and Dooley and
do we and Dooley what is it and what is
it
and do it and do we anyway andouille
sausage and do uh Ratatouille uh anybody
want and then we sauce
what's the thing that uh New Orleans is
famous crawdad crawfish crawfish uh
Cajun Cajun
got some Creole oatmeal going on in the
morning
um we'll give you diarrhea so bad chill
Mitchell's like nah not that and so um
yeah so that's what it's about and it's
just [ __ ] amazing and he's always
cooking in the beginning and at the end
like dude he is investigating murders
and also waking up to cook
dope [ __ ] and his name is Dwayne pride
and he goes by King so I want to know is
Daryl Mitchell he's the only Daryl chill
Mitchell in NCIS I don't see Daryl chill
Mitchell in everything can we find that
out I don't know like he's been in a lot
of stuff and he's killing it oh well
then let's let's find out for sure does
he go by Daryl chill Mitchell and
everything because if he does he's
figured out life way better than anybody
else I gotta have a middle name like
that
oh go to his Instagram maybe it says
Daryl chill Mitchell in it
it doesn't come up as anything else
though
it is dude the hat in the second one is
that him a condom is that him I think
yeah wow look at this [ __ ] stuff dude
who knows
wow
yeah I know we can't play that but um
anyway he's the [ __ ] oh man you guys got
so much money from that you know well
good for him yeah good for him for sure
he figured out life he got people to
call him Daryl chill Mitchell on the on
the on the intro oh he's in Sergeant
Bilko dude how does a guy who has he's
been in a lot of yeah for a paralyzed
guy that's that's
he's the best paralyzed actor I mean
unless he it happened and he kept on
acting he's in something called Lifeline
really yeah scroll down
he should we shoot him on the show
that's hilarious there it is oh wow
2017. he's out about two guys give
advice
oh wow look at that
I don't know a single person in that
show that's cool uncle has a 3.9 oh out
of five
uh all right let's let's do let's do
another one there's enough there's
enough but it's fun to do that though
yeah that was fun
oh the sexiest man I've ever seen in my
life David Arquette
um I have a situation
making how much [ __ ] how much is he
making a world ending robot
um
that'll pan out no dude he's currently
making this video stranded somewhere and
he's making something that will save his
life this guy is hilarious and the [ __ ]
and the fact that he's fixing something
off screen is absolutely unfucking you
know who this guy's he's David the [ __ ]
Arquette that's who that is okay
I'm having a difficult time
uh evil villain
explaining what
I'm gonna kill someone it's a [ __ ]
means okay to him and
there's so many nuances to it that's
right I'm learning he's right like
like if you're mowing the lawn and you
know at the end when you're doing the
little little triangles and like turning
into all these little it's a [ __ ] right
you know that's the [ __ ] but also very
good I've come to like realize
I feel like you know your ego is the
[ __ ] too yeah yeah yeah oh it's so
[ __ ] to be like
bitching about something sure
but it comes across so
judgmental to people who yeah okay yeah
okay let's discuss uh here it is
judgmental because it kind of is yes you
know yeah but I've like no keep on the
little that's great it's a [ __ ] in me
because it's the best teacher
of what needs to grow and change
beautiful man I'm trying to communicate
that to somebody and I'm having a really
hard time because there's so many
different examples of fish there's so
many different it's a [ __ ] I was using
the screwdrome meaning it's a great
example of it's a [ __ ] equals the [ __ ]
yeah it's like I am judging myself
for being so [ __ ] but it's also like I
love myself I'm not taking it so
seriously no way around being a [ __ ]
everybody's a [ __ ] everybody when
someone says something hey you really
hurt my feelings with something and if I
went
oh you didn't understand what I mean
it's a [ __ ]
in a way you know what I mean
so I'm trying to I mean I love the term
because it's it's helped me so much but
I'm not like condemning myself when I
see that little ego that little [ __ ]
that wants to hey I'm right okay
uh here here's the way to in terms of
explaining it to other people the thing
that people get tripped up on is that
they think if you say [ __ ] about
something they do they think you're
calling them a [ __ ] yeah moreover they
think it has anything to do and I
understand why they would think this
they think it has something to do with
like the when men call women oh they do
a [ __ ] which is totally not at all what
it is yeah I know it has nothing to do
with that no so it's good to be able to
clear that up but it's it's the
lawnmower example was perfect because
it's like or like when you're carrying
something irregular and you're trying to
fit through a doorway you're doing the
lawn mower you're like it's like your
arms don't fit around the thing and
you're trying to right that's cement
yeah yeah I mean so that has nothing to
do with the derogatory term [ __ ] ever
in fact if you use it that way that's
absolutely Incorrect and and you're
fired I was yeah I was a [ __ ] yesterday
I I I'm and I don't know if I was a
[ __ ] today yet but I would say I'm
probably a [ __ ] at least once a day
yeah do you ever
do you ever notice that you are being
doing something that is a [ __ ] when
you're alone and you laugh any you laugh
oh yeah yeah me too yeah you do yeah
yeah yeah
and you ask because you wish somebody
saw it so yeah I would say [ __ ] to it
yeah yeah for sure I want to explain it
to you but you can't explain it to
somebody you got to show it to him and
then you're right right even though if
it's really funny you can explain it yes
because then you you can really convey
yeah someone like toppling over with
books or something yeah um yeah there's
nothing wrong with the [ __ ] because we
are also [ __ ] yes all of us remember
when dad fell when he was trying to do
the magician thing
fell later but look at this was the best
thing the whole thing was a [ __ ] but
look at this was the funniest thing that
I've ever seen before both times
did he fall wasn't that the thing he
fell he fell
he was going we was we were playing a
game yeah where he had to say we had to
guess magician but he couldn't say he
was like taboo or whatever somebody and
he was it wasn't taboo but it was like
taboo and he was trying to do like a
voila thing yeah I in my memory he fell
while he was doing it got up and then
goes look oh my god really and it was so
I thought the fall was separate and I
just thought look at it all I remember
is
look at this like what's such a say a
thing a magician says like Abracadabra I
couldn't say average right right that
was one of the words yeah oh [ __ ] you
just said look at this the worst
magician you know look at this [ __ ]
cut a girl laugh look at this okay so
look what I'm doing
um yeah so I I would say so it's a bit
what are you laughing at specifically
right now
foreign
a magician if a magician really did a
trick and said look at this but I'm also
laughing at the way Dad did it it was so
funny dude it was yeah
oh [ __ ] we laughed and so all right so
yeah so [ __ ] is a great [ __ ] thing
it costs people out but in a lot it's a
loving thing dude just tell them it's a
loving thing I know I mean maybe they
get offended
we're taking the word and owning the
word it's not [ __ ] what it means
actually it doesn't mean female dog it's
not a derogatory theme for women yeah
we're taking that word and saying wow
you really look insecure the way you're
moving around yeah right exactly yeah
totally yeah or or like overwhelmed but
physically physically Swallowed at the
wrong time in the conversation they're
trying to do something awkward yep that
requires your body to move in a it's a
easy position anyway physically it's a
[ __ ] that requires you this is a [ __ ]
right right okay cool let's see what's
up that was good yeah
good great question hey man and Chris
love the pothole hope you guys are doing
well I'm seeking some dating and
relationship advice I met this girl we
were going on dates really hitting it
off doing the horizontal Mambo life was
ripping for about a month sounds good we
were spending four or five days in a row
hanging out each week which became
exhausting and I told her I think we're
spending too much time together it was
in delicate how I said it and it came
out at the wrong time
um I really hurt her feelings and she
told me I'm a bad purse and that she
doesn't want to see me again
two weeks later she reached out we met
up and talked she apologized we agreed
we wanted things to be back to how they
were
um
but ever since then it's been about
three or four weeks the Hangouts have
been infrequent it doesn't feel the same
her texts have been dry and she's been
leaving me on red I was curious should I
reach out and see you know how she's
feeling
um and if this happened to you how'd you
handle it and how to pan out yeah thanks
okay wait before we even get into that
leaving someone on red I want to talk
about this I think about this sometimes
people are real water people are always
like oh I'm gonna leave them on red like
show them something oh let him oh let
him suffer on red yeah it's like
leaving somebody on red you know who
leaves [ __ ] unread people who have a
life dude like I don't respond right
away to any of any people who text me
yeah and I also don't have red receipts
which is change it for everyone don't
ever have that but like I I don't know I
don't I don't find that insulting if
someone read my text
three hours or three days before and
hasn't responded yet
um I'm codependent though so I do okay
well I don't so I'm smarter and have it
more figured out than you so that's the
final word on that part yeah but but
this guy I knew what when he was saying
it that that was a huge mistake why why
do people do that why are people like
what like this guy why is does he say oh
maybe we're seeing each maybe maybe
we're moving too fast maybe or maybe
we're seeing each other too much like
what you're you're seeing her because
you want to yeah so if you want to why
would you even want to scale back in the
first place like there's no like set
ideal of how often you see somebody you
see somebody the amount that you want to
see them yeah so why would he well he
either in in all like do all due respect
[ __ ] it up by saying because he's
fearful avoidant or he is uh he he
doesn't like her that much but he
obviously does sure yeah but me
sometimes it takes it takes well okay so
if he's somebody who keeps people at a
distance because he's scared because his
walls are up if that's what it is then
he should say that to her so that he has
an explanation for saying that but
there's many people who are like that
that don't know they're like that okay
well congratulations now you know say
that in the text say say like I don't
know why I said that that was stupid not
only did it come out wrong but like I
think I had some like
fear of wearing myself out on like with
you and I don't I'm scared to wear
myself out with you so like hopefully I
was wrong I I don't know what I was
thinking it was a stupid thing to say
like obviously things were good then if
we could get back to where we were that
would be amazing I'm sorry is yeah you
think so you think he's I wasn't really
clear is you think he he so he wants to
does he want it to get back to the way
it was yeah it seems like it to me yeah
yeah I guess it did seem like that yeah
just say that say like yo I don't know
why I said that I jumped the gun I think
I was being a little bit of fear a
little bit fearful I was insecure or
whatever but uh I noticed your texts
have been dry lately and if it's because
of a reaction because of that because
you think you need to be that way
because I said that I understand but let
me take accountability and
responsibility for that so and tell you
that that isn't what I meant isn't what
I meant I was being you know not true to
myself I was scared and uh I'd love to
you know uh stop that [ __ ] and let's
move and then let's move forward
or
laughing that hard made me tired man wow
yeah or you know maybe you're just you
don't want to be with her you gotta yeah
she does though he wouldn't do this I I
understand but I'm just trying to think
like if I like I would have never done
that well I'm a different I'm not
fearful of it and I'm very uh I'm very
codependent but yeah okay I don't know
yeah
take massive life just yeah take my
advice a baby hey what's up everybody
get right into it it's the same color
the other night four months old I was
with this girl that I've known for a few
weeks and you know things escalated we
was going through the horizontal Mamba
nice but she told me
oh I don't like condoms when I pulled
out the Rubber and I'm like
aren't you worried about having a kid
STDs great she's like oh I'm on birth
control don't worry I get checked all
the time I'm clean what about you so I
just wanted to know what you boys would
do in this situation are you telling her
hey sorry I gotta keep myself protected
can't do it great question or is it like
depends on
the scale of if she's a bombshell or
like you know yeah
it all depends just save the world just
shoot his parents yeah like a one versus
ten are you you going in raw with the 10
or is it just a No Deal all around gotta
protect yourself gotta stay clean yeah
let me know okay if go ahead if you guys
gotta be clean you gotta be yeah you
gotta be clean here's the deal though if
you don't have your own car you can do
it
because she might be better off than you
and then like you guys could figure out
life together because it sucks if you
don't have a car you're saying you can
hit your wagon to someone who has is
better off than you if you have a baby
but is he it's a birth control he said
but he's talking about well yeah but
here's the thing it's not news but
people be lying okay but here's the
thing
if someone says that to you
yes you yes in this case it's the woman
she's saying I've been tested and I'm on
birth control but like what about
sorry to break it to you all the guys
out there you're not the only one that
this woman might be having sex with so
like
not even in a distrustful way just in
like a safe way yeah you just always
want to wear a condom if it's your if
it's your partner and you guys are
exclusive obviously yeah then who cares
but like
but he's talking he's with a 10. why
does that matter I don't understand
because you get to the same exact thing
biologically yeah I know something and
you can get someone pregnant and a lot
of things you don't have your own car
and if you live with a roommate and
you're 29 or up up above that and you
have a 10. that's not happening though
because you're 29 have a roommate and
don't have a car depends on where you
are dude if you're in the [ __ ] the
the if you live in a swamp land you know
what I mean if you live if you're on a
bayou and like you just got the dime
there by mistake like what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] show in Canada like there's
people that live in the middle of
nowhere there's a really hot you know
chick in it all right I mean that's an
extreme but I'm just saying though like
you you you you you knock her up by
mistake and you don't have a car and you
live with a roommate she all of a sudden
makes you look good and we're elevated
right and then all of a sudden all right
it's like the [ __ ] secret or you made
your own vision board but the nutting
the don't worry I'm on birth control
is a there's a glaring hole in that
state yes because what about other
things well no but also not just worried
about children I get it you're not going
to get HIV and pretty much everything
else is whatever curable except for
herpes but here's the deal you're just
chill about STIs why no but well I mean
herpes is the bad one and then otherwise
you can just kind of take a pill right
yeah but it's like I mean what are you
talking about what I'm worried about
more is uh people be lying first of all
about the birth control and then second
of all Sometimes women will be like I
take birth control and they take it
every day but not every day at 10 A.M
they take it at 10 A.M they take it at 3
P.M they ticket it and then the pill
doesn't know what to do and Whoopsie
Daisy I let my [ __ ] soldiers in there
and now we've got a kid but all of the
everything we're saying actually doesn't
matter whether it's you're afraid of
getting an STD or getting someone
pregnant or if you're the woman you
don't trust a guy who says he's been
tested recently which you shouldn't
always with someone who you're not
exclusive with always insist on
protection whether you're a woman or the
man Bing Bong okay yep
hey Chris Matt my name is Marta I'm 30
years old and I live in Brooklyn and
unfortunately I need some help with a
stranger danger problem no
um
a little background I have volunteer job
that I do Tuesday mornings I um feed a
colony of stray cats cool I know your
dog people apologies
um and there's been this man that's been
showing up
um
to the place every Tuesday morning when
I'm there for like about a month and he
just asks me the same questions over and
over again and I feel like I've been
pretty like polite about it I've been
like Okay
um
yeah he asks me what what am I doing uh
[Music]
how many of the cats do I own oh man I
don't own any of them they're wild
um and just all the food get eaten which
arguably is the weirdest question out of
all of them so I don't really know what
to do should I like ignore him should I
no
I don't know should I spin moo not sorry
um
yeah I mean obviously he's crazy right
yes what do I do
uh bring somebody next time bring
somebody whether that's a a girlfriend
or a man bring somebody and have that
person say something to that person
because it's a situation that could get
Harry if you are
if it could go sideways in a number of
ways with a crazy person so you bring
someone as as like a buffer as
protection but also to be the person to
be like
create some kind of like
uh pushback like why are you what she
says you ask questions of it if it's a
guy he should just be like what do you
why do you ask the same heard the same
questions every week like she told me
about you I'm like what what is that
about or something you know I think you
bring somebody uh at least once maybe
twice in a row because if you confront
the guy the first time you want to make
sure that you're protected the next time
you go unfortunately
in any City you know you're in Brooklyn
I used to live in New York there's a
number of
scenarios where there's just a crazy guy
who gets in the way all the time I used
to live downtown and there was a really
crazy guy who used to pretend like he
worked in the parking lot that I parked
my car in and he was just a crazy guy
he would like ask if I wanted to get my
like windshield clean or like whatever
and I was just like at a certain point I
was like you don't work here you did I
know that yeah you know what I mean I
know you don't work here he was he I
don't even remember what he said it
wasn't even the point like he was a
crazy guy you know it didn't matter uh
what I said he was going to keep doing
what he was doing but uh you know I'm a
six foot one man and that's that's an
immediate difference right there I think
you should bring bring a guy at least
bring a friend of some kind yeah
absolutely have to there's no question
yeah it did you never know what the [ __ ]
could happen if people are crazy yeah
yeah 100 yeah all right nothing
I mean
I agree with you okay like there's
nothing else to say but [ __ ] you got
to be careful yeah and bring bring a
friend to confront the person or bring a
friend in you confront him when the
friend is there so you have like backup
that's good too but I still think
through the the big guy do it yeah yeah
of course yeah yeah every chick has a
big guy friend yeah
um I'll be quick an expertise
um I recently got out of a long-term
relationship about a little over a year
and I have completely forgotten how to
speak to women yeah get it
zero game no play whatsoever
um
advice tactics anything please
thank you first of all stop thinking
about that because like every day is a
new day every interaction is a new
interaction you know you could be to
[ __ ] you know
The Nutty Professor in one instance and
then you're lothario the next like every
day is a clean slate every person is a
clean slate
just don't be a jerk and don't be
insecure you know what I mean like
though there's a vast Territory between
those two things you don't need any
skills there's any anybody that's out
there being like I know how to pick up
girls is is an absolute like huckster
right those people are full of [ __ ] and
because it's it's like there is no one
size fits-all thing it also that's like
belittling to everyone involved it's
like as if there's like a trick you can
pull on women to make them want to have
sex with you like this yeah this is not
remotely true first of all yeah and
second of all like doesn't everybody
know that that's not true by now anyway
not to say that's what they're saying
but like I don't think there is or I
know that there is not uh
a right thing to do in terms of like
getting women it's just like you you'll
be good I mean it's always be you yeah
to be you yeah because eventually anyway
they're gonna discover who you are so
yeah so be open and honest and say hey
look you know uh I I've been in a
relationship by the way how long a year
he said he's been out of it for about a
year yeah oh okay he's out of it for a
year and I think that's what he said
yeah yeah
um and also put yourself into situations
that will help you figure it out like go
to a place that where you approach
someone and talk to them you'll get
better at it and you'll get a thicker
skin for sure also definitely definitely
this might be the most important but be
easy on yourself yeah yeah as long as
you're not being a jerk and like getting
drinks thrown in your face or getting
the eyes rolled at you like as long as
you're not being mean or nagging which
I'm assuming this guy isn't he seems
like a nice guy yeah he does uh but
don't take it personally don't be hard
on yourself
not everybody likes everybody like it's
just like one of those things you could
be on a bad streak it could be
approaching the wrong people I highly
doubt it has to do with the way you're
approaching people you know uh unless
again you're getting in your own head
that sounds like that's the thing you
got to stop there's no tips and tactics
except for just be yourself
I've done every just remember that every
time you approach someone in this way
it's you have a clean slate they don't
remember the dumb thing you said to the
person the other last couple weeks a
couple weeks ago like they weren't there
you are a new person to this new person
you are new to this that's true you're
not new to you you're the same old idiot
to yourself yes everybody's the same old
idiot to themselves yes but to the
person that you're meeting right now
right in front of you you're new to them
give yourself a [ __ ] break yeah yeah
give yourself a break be you give
yourself a break those are the two
things a hundred percent okay and also
congratulations on your snowboarding
that you obviously yeah congratulations
on all the trophies you won so cool you
want to do one more yeah cool
falling hey guys Lulu from New York City
here so I'll find out in the background
as always can't see of course I'm a long
time baby Matt big fan of your work
watched American animal recently oh yeah
my question for you both is how do you
manage anxiety when you're sort of in
the public eye
um I'm a musician performer uh I go on
stage a lot I'm getting kind of well
known for what I do but I deal with
panic attacks um I struggle with like
OCD Chris I know same for you
um you know just when you're panicking
they have to be on stage or in front of
people it can be really scary I'm in
therapy uh of course it's helpful
history betterhelp.com but always the
advice I'm looking for so I guess as two
successful dudes with careers and
families and whatnot and who survived um
you know almost blocking out on a plane
how you manage anxiety when you're
either on stage or in front of or behind
a camera I'm also a licensed
psychotherapist so sometimes it's hard
to give myself my own advice a deeper
whatever anyway that's it love you guys
Chris see you February 18th Matt you got
beautiful hands all right
New York uh yeah it's weird too
especially because I have some too but
no no I have beautiful hands she said
hmm people say that about you huh I mean
yeah I mean I I think
well did you get it or not I get it a
lot since we started doing this better
than mine I mean my hands look way
better than yours okay but I I don't
know uh yeah uh I mean you can speak
better this than I can but I I don't
like I mean I don't mind like being
recognized because everybody would
recognize me is generally very nice to
me uh because they know who I am because
they're a fan of one thing or another
but I generally
share your anxiety uh and I'm a [ __ ]
hermit okay your turn
that's my solution but that's not a good
solution it's tough I mean look you know
it's all about the work right you're a
singer and uh
part of the reason why
you're good at what you do is because of
this stuff you're very sensitive and the
OCD is about control and you want to try
and control the situation and you can't
and I get that uh I live that way as
well and
um I think that what you got to do is
just well first of all there are things
you can do for like OCD and there's
behavioral therapy and there is a brain
a book called brain lock that's really
good if you look it up
um and you get it but but you know
dealing with the stuff and dealing with
it in your career uh we're in an age now
where you can just kind of be
transparent and and talk about it too
you can write a song about it it can
fuel your work so you know I understand
the the feeling Shame about it trust me
and I understand the hardship of it but
you can just use it to actually fuel
yourself and make you a better person
and make yourself a better artist so uh
you know
it's not
you the OCD and the panic attacks but
it's a part of your makeup and
and that's okay and you can get through
it uh
remember that it's your brain but you
didn't ask for it you simply didn't
design it so it's a part of you and as
artists or as an artist in your case
just sort of like if you can the ideal
thing is to fold it in to your persona
and your work if possible and that is
not just being open about it but as
Chris is saying uh you said she's a
singer that's what she said okay uh yeah
making music about it not like on the
nose but yeah I have OCT but yeah
actually that would be good think about
that would be that'd be amazing
um but uh yeah I think that there are a
number of ways of dealing with it
through the work yeah through the
Persona that you're creating uh for the
public just love yourself man
you know talking to me be okay with it
yeah no okay be okay with it you're okay
you're okay and don't don't uh don't
kill yourself over it you're you're a
good person well I mean I mean I mean
that I don't mean that actually no I
know yeah yeah colloquially I got you
okay all right well thanks for listening
uh you can go to chrisley.com I'm gonna
be in San Diego tonight christie.com
I'll be in New York February 18th I'll
see that uh lovely lady there
um at the Beacon Theater and I will be
in Chicago I will be in Portland and
Daytona and Seattle a bunch of places
chrisley.com Breya improv I will be
doing dates there in California uh let
me know one-on-one sessions with me uh
Dwayne Pride go get your session uh Book
Em at matalia.com
uh tickets for him is christalia.com uh
and yeah uh oh the lifeline merch life
onmurch.com get it keep yourself warm
look good make everybody happy buy it
for everybody that you've ever met and
we're good [ __ ] yeah dude thanks guys
[Music]